[Music]
your life people ask how I got into
donating to various causes and how I got
involved in even homelessness along the
way and popped out of it well it's a
very interesting story my mom asked a
lot to do with it at six years old we
didn't have any money there was my
mother my brother and I we had a
deadbeat dad left us before we were two
but she took us at Christmastime to
downtown Los Angeles we had little cars
going around in circles is pretty cool
anyway some decorations in the window
she gave my brother and I had time until
his boys hold half of it each give to
the man ringing the bell in the bucket
we put it in this bucket we said mom why
do we give that man a dime that's like
two soda pops this is 1951 two soda pops
three candy bars and mom said boys
that's the Salvation Army now they take
care of people that have no place to
live and no food and we don't have a lot
of money but we could afford a dime this
year boys always remember in life give a
little something to those in need
they'll always be somebody that's not as
well off as you are no matter where you
are how far down you are trying to have
someone along the way it stuck with me
first time I was homeless was two and a
half oh my god they'd over first time I
was homeless I was twenty two and a half
years old and I had a two and a half
year old son I was working as the master
of ceremonies at the second annual
sports vacation recreational vehicle
show and had a check coming in at the
end of the week well I came home and I
drove her a 1 car up to where we lived
and as I was getting out of the car and
going up towards our apartment door my
wife we very young by we got married at
20 and 19 years old my wife was coming
down the stairs and she said one of the
story she took the keys by the time I
got through the door I saw my little boy
two and a half years old kind of just
sitting there on top of a pile of
clothes with a note that basically said
I can't handle being a mom anymore he'll
be much better off with you good luck
now what I didn't know also was that she
had planned this for a few months she
had not paid the rent for a few months
and kept the money and I didn't know
that she wiped out what little we had in
the savings account in the bank and took
the only car we had so unbeknownst to me
two days later I was evicted completely
evicted power shut off the landlord
just type this one and I had this little
kitten with me two and a half years old
and nine to be mom and dad and that was
really a bummer I had no car so I ended
up borrowing the 1951 Cadillac with a
broken water-pump from someone that was
very very dear have put water in it
every four hours and that's kind of how
we got going second time I was homeless
is when I started John Paul Mitchell
Systems I knew I needed half a million
dollars to start John Paul Mitchell
Systems had to have that so we had the
backer lined up I had a good job at the
time than a nice house and I left
everything I had because half a million
dollars was coming in down the street I
was in starting company so I left it all
behind I left what money I had with my
wife we working along well at all and
the best car and I took the older car
was a good one but an older car ran good
down the hill to get my money I would
check into an efficiency hotel and then
because I'd be traveling a lot and
eventually in an apartment when I went
down the hill the backer pulled out no
money well it was later that afternoon
that a friend of mine found me and said
John Paul please call dick Holthaus
direct collect in England he doesn't
have the best news for you so I got
ahold of him for him was the wee hours
of the morning and he said JP the backer
pulled out the reason he pulled out was
inflation in the United States was
twelve and a half percent unemployment
ten percent actually over ten percent
interest rates if you could get a loan
prime rate was seventeen percent
interest and we still had hostages that
I ran and we waited in line for gasoline
that was the environment the United
States in 1980 and 1981 well there I was
a few hundred dollars in my pocket too
proud to ask my mother if I could have
my old room back for my in the home and
she could feed me for a couple of months
I get back on my feet and I just left my
living situation I was too proud stupid
but very very proud so I went by and saw
my mom and uh you know I was borrowed a
couple hundred dollars from her I said
mom we'll give it back to you she said
son you're doing really well in life why
didn't a few hundred dollars as a mom
like give it back to him I'm starting
something new
and that's why I decided I'm gonna make
it I'm not gonna tell her
lived in my car shower down at Griffith
Park because they had tennis courts
there was showers in it and learned how
to live off very little and go ahead and
sell products door-to-door when I was
homeless on my mind was not oh my god
how did I get here who's to blame on
this what was in my mind was okay after
I cried a little bit the two and a half
year old son not knowing what to do no
money no nothing my first thought was
okay I need to get some money and I want
to go to my mom's house and tell her how
bad things are I need to get money to
eat and we're sources of money we don't
have any money so I went around
collecting soda pop bottles from empty
lots and at that time a grocery store or
any liquor store will give you two cents
for little one five cents for a big one
went around collected a lot of them cash
in that's how he got the money and so we
were able to eat now when I got evicted
out of the house a three days later this
is when I was 22 and a half years old
when I was completely evicted now he had
that car I had borrowed to live in and
we went more towards fast foods that
were halfway prepared for you those are
the early days of fast food just to eat
a few days later a friend of mine foul
makes he knew I was hanging out talked
to some friends of mine named Lee Mayer
and Lee said Johnny I've got a house
with an extra room he was a biker a real
heavy-duty biker and he says you and
your son can live here to get on your
feet no problem we could have some of
the biker mamas take care of your son
while you're working and let's move on
we're buddies and that was a big helping
hand I think whether you have money or
don't have money it's very important to
give back because it's we the people
individuals that make the planet better
so that this doesn't happen again it
makes it better for other people it's we
the people if we don't help others out
and people start going down then what do
we expect as future customers or future
people helps us out if we were in
trouble
so I feel that every human being has the
obligation paint a little bit of red for
being on this planet to do something
good for their city or their state or
their country or even the world to make
it a better place to live now if you
don't have any money it's okay
you could volunteer like I don't have
any money
Thanksgiving Christmas up at Griffith
Park in California helping feed the
homeless or do something up somebody
else out to make the world a better
place to live no benefits by this
whenever you do something for somebody
else and ask them absolutely nothing in
return you get the greatest high you
could ever have in your life and it
makes you more connected with the whole
planet a lot of people think they have
to give huge amount of money to make the
impact well I would disagree with them
because I remember back my mom well we
had almost nothing knew the importance
of giving two little boys a dime to put
in the bucket because she knows times
became many dimes many dollars and many
$10 bills but every little bit gives
back every little bit so no matter how
little you give or a little of your time
you donate you've done a little
something that little something makes a
difference
[Music]
you